ladies and gentlemen welcome everyone
both here in Stockholm and everyone
following us around the world on YouTube
to this press conference hosted in
connection with the signing of the
global sponsorship agreement between
unibit and the world's best chess player
and world champion Magnus Carlsen it's
all about the preparation the hard work
doing the same thing over and over and
over again making your body ready
[Music]
[Music]
your soul
powers once years of work
we'll never stop making the most out of
every single thing
[Music]
then you might be lucky
[Applause]
as of today universe has assigned a
commercial agreement with magnus carlsen
making innovate poisons main sponsor for
2020 and 2021 magnus carlsen is a
highest-rated chess player in history he
entered 2020 as world number one for the
11th consecutive time his chess world
champion since 2013
currently world champion in classical
rapid and blitz and also the world
record holder in number of classical
games without a loss so far 120 games he
will throughout this partnership be a
gold global ambassador for unibit the
next two years some practical elements
here today we will start with a
statement from Magnus Carlsen followed
by a statement by chief commercial
officer of kinetic group raw Rodri dark
after the statements we will open up for
around questions from media after the
plenary questions mr. Carsen Amissah
Doric will meet on the chess board for a
very instructive game of chess you are
welcome to film and photograph we will
end this session with 1 to 1 in tears
so welcome into the room World Chess
Champion known as Carson and chief
commercial officer of Canary group wrote
a dark in if just a few seconds when mr.
dark and mr. Carson is arriving they
will be placed here on these tables and
also as I mentioned afterwards the
chance pebble chess table will be used
for a photo session that can be
photographed and filmed from the media
and after we have done with that we will
do one-to-one sessions and in a few
quite a few seconds now we will have
both mr. dark and mr. Carson here at the
stage we just need to give them their
microphones and then everybody also on
the internet will be able to hear them
when they do their statements so just
give us a few seconds and they'll be on
stage
so it sounds like they are closing in
right now so it's a pleasure to welcome
into the room the new global ambassador
of unibit and also world chess champion
among this carson and chief commercial
officer kinder group wrote a dark
welcome both to this press conference
magnus could you kick this off with your
thoughts about why this is a good
partnership for you i think it's it's a
good partnership because we share a lot
of common values and interests such as
analytical analytical approach to to
games and i think it's going to be a
very exciting moving forward seeing as
you know bet this is a global brand and
obviously we share other other interests
us as well for me this is something
that's become also more natural fit
after what happened last last summer and
all us sort of being on the same same
side of a of a major discussion Thank
You mr. Doric why is this a partnership
a good thing for kinder gonna bet hey
Lou :
we're delighted to announce a I think
Magnus is a huge star reigning world
number 1 since 2010 I mean we've been
following I joined the company in 2009
and we were discussing around chess as
far back as 2010 now we've seen a
phenomenal growth in chess and we've
seen our own interest growing in chess
2014 we were the first international
betting operator to offer live odds on
chess so really we have a strong
interest in chess as Magnus says you
know we also have a lot of common
interests NBA football poker
man chess you know and again as I say we
see a huge opportunity there
I think Magnus is also a perfect
embodiment of the Union bet kind of
brand positioning so we talked about
Lucky's no coincidence and that's really
about making great decisions using date
when we're trying to encourage our
players to use data statistics and
really think analytically and make sound
choices either about how they choose to
use the tools we offer to play
responsibly or how they find an edge and
how they kind of find the very best
opportunity and who else to embody that
the Magnus is a great great ambassador
for us on that we also see a great
opportunity going forwards in chess I
mean we as you say we've been improving
our offering significantly since 2014 we
continue to do that we often see on a
you know a big matchday on a big kind of
chess tournament as many players
interested or active around chess as we
do on Premier League or some of the big
international football of them so it
shows that there's a real clear appetite
amongst our global audience and there's
a growing audience you know 600 million
kind of worldwide
and that's an area that we we would love
to be a part of we love to increase our
participation in that and see if we can
bring something extra into that space so
to sum up very excited really looking
forward to and I think it's gonna be a
great partnership so thank you and thank
you thank you we will now open up for
questions from media in the plenary
session since we are streaming please
use the microphone that Martine will
provide you also your questions in
English and please state your name and
which media you are representing so
first one almost from dog run all right
could you tell a bit about what
considerations you did before signing
this deal to be honest this is the deal
I've been excited about for for a long
time as as rod Reese talked about and
and I talked about a bit as well
we felt that
this would be a great fit and a very
fruitful partnership going going forward
so obviously there were considerations
to take considering that I have other
partners in in other fields as well but
I think at the end of the day we're very
happy with wherever we landed could you
also please just tell a bit about what
expectations you have reactions you are
expecting back in Norway there was a lot
of discussions this summer
I I don't think I'm the person who
should speculate on on possible
reactions you are the media and that's
that is your job
since you are hoping for what what I'm
hoping for is to for for people to to
share some of the excitement that we
feel about this corporation even from an
RK we're going to promote unibit home in
Norway
I will not promote University in in with
with Brandon in branding in Norway that
is this is a global partnership and we
adhere to in which in law yeah I mean
this is a global deal for us Simon
Magnus is a huge international star we
have a very broad international
geographical footprint and there's one
the reasons that we were so keen and see
such a good opportunity I think you guys
have seen the TVC or will see the TVC it
looks excellent we're super happy with
it
and it will play really well across all
markets anyone else yep
Judis from teaching sweden - how do you
think this deal will has changed your
possibilities - to keep on playing just
to be honest I think the there will not
be any fewer possibilities I think a
global partnership with like this will
open up more opportunities around the
world so I don't see see any
difficulties there thank you final
question before we go to one to one
no okay well first we will do a short
short photo session of the chess board I
would like to invite mr. Carson mr.
doric to the chess board for a game of
very instructive yes I understand the
dark is not a very seasoned chess player
but what better way to start than with a
lesson from the world champion yeah so
yeah I don't know starting out you can
make moves in the center with the pawns
yeah to control these middle squares
especially then you can move more more
easily around I was trying to research
last night and I was kind of like target
for this opening target but this opening
do you for this opening this is even
better now I get to learn from the
master yeah exactly so you can look at
it a bit like like football if you
control the middle then you can attack
more easily um yeah the flanks you know
and if you overload on one flank then
the others will will have to to overload
you can switch to the others cos these
multiple things and obviously use most
multiple openings but most of them will
be connected with controlling especially
these four squares yeah this is the most
popular move then
then you know you go either you do the
same - to control the same amount of
squares or you this one yes a moving our
knife soft early as good so whatever
Knights you want to move
that's excellent you know it's one of my
favorite openings
yeah - the fried liver exam mmm not
exactly
that's connected with that were there
with the other one so you can go yeah
good Bishop yeah the bishop is good
excellent if I get a beating in less
than three as I know that's everything
good so far you can use the other night
if you want
yeah yeah and then get the bishop out
and it's also a good idea to castle
early on okay so change the king and
rook yeah yeah okay yeah we're good
yep yeah no damage done thank you who
won thank you can we consider the draw
week we can yes sir all right
good we'll go to one to one then I'll
organize the one to one with the media
was already requested for mr. Carson
Kindred's group of head of communication
all these on the rivers trail who is
there we'll organize the one to ones for
mr. Doric
if anyone would like to do that also in
the room is mr. Henry Carson father of
Magnus will be able for one-to-one or
practical questions and paper on link
head of public affairs is also here to
answer any questions regarding kyndra's
public appearance in a Norwegian market
this ends the stream thank you everyone
for us follow the stream online and now
we go to one-to-one we start with NRK